first round it was actually better than
I expected
some of you guys were pulling off some
big plays
I was happy with what I was seeing but I
think there's still a little bit of room
for improvement for all of you so wheres
he has been really good all I kind of
imagined him being sterner what are you
guys doing okay
well I was really happy in general I saw
some big improvements in infantry play
that's what we kind of focused on in
that first game 22 damage 44 yes down
every wife nice one boys is why we work
better as a squad we were communicating
a lot more shouting at each other
whatever the communication is it's just
sometimes important to tell people it's
loads of them Cena I saw a lot of
improvement from Benny because we were
moving between three different capture
points and it was over quite a long
range so he was able to use his sniper
rifle effectively oh sure and then you
had Brad coming in with his ammo always
making sure he was there to resupply and
we hovered around the town quiet a lot
which was kind of important because they
kept taking the sea flag back but we all
sort of stuck together stuck around that
area and held out flag till the end of
the round so it's actually very
impressed with what they would do would
we won the match we communicate
effectively we all kind of coalesce to
the same God someone fell down the other
one pick them up and you can just see
how a little bit of a knowledge a bit of
skill and a lot of communication can
really help to make us a better
battlefield squad but all the little I
will all focus we all going from one
place to another scenes but dumb one
cause we know what we're doing next all
together it's great we worked so much
better as a team we were sticking
together we're giving each other ammo
health as being able to pick up some
really nice shots which I was really
happy where there was this one section
where I was like what what is going on
us picking up killers all over the place
oh my god that was a shot and the first
game we're a bit like I guess I should
go over here and I guess at tactic would
be to run towards this building but but
now I'm like impartial eager than know
the map but also because I know the best
way to attack certain point because of
wes is teaching so yeah definitely
improvement okay so that was a really
good session much happier with your
infantry player we played together as a
squad we've spawned in at different
classes when we needed to but you'll had
to find roles and you knew how to play
them by the end of the round the
communication was really good so I'm
really happy with your infantry play now
but there's one thing that we haven't
really focused on you and that's
vehicles there's a really good reason
for that because they can just be so so
different to playing as infantry so we
will talk about those a little bit now
because i know you have like some
questions about how
account of them and sort of how you can
get rid of them or maybe how you can
best utilize certain vehicle so we'll
start with the tanks so there's three
different types of tanks that you can
use you've got the light tank which is
the small one and it kind of looks like
a duck then you've got the the landship
which is the mark five it's a British
tank and then finally you've got the
heavy tank which is the a7v and that's a
German tank and you can get six people
in that tank now the light tanks the
easiest to take down because it's
smaller so you can throw anti-tank
grenades at it it will do a fair amount
of damage you can also use the K bullets
a scalp yeah really is the medic I don't
really know what you can do against one
of those it's best to maybe take cover
and just just drop some health for your
other players crew as support as support
though you can drop down like the ammo
bags and that will replenish people's
grenades so in August keep firing yeah
like if you drop those bags down they
will automatically fly towards the
player who's nearest them if they need
it and that will replenish your grenade
and that someone can throw another one
towards it the land ship is a little bit
harder to take down up see it's a bigger
tank it's with more armor there is
directional damage on tank so you hit
them from behind you will do more damage
than if you hit them from the front so
it's worth maybe using some of those
field guns you know the cannons with the
big wheels on the side they're sort of
around all the objectives and then
finally you've got the heavy tank those
things are very very powerful because
they can see all around you it's very
difficult to counter those as infantry
unless there are lots of you sort of all
different directions throwing explosives
maybe using the rocket gun as a sole
which is something you can unlock but
the heavy tank is really something that
the planes can help take down because
they've got a lot more firepower if we
get to use the planes at all because
some of you might be able to spawn in
those in the next round that we play
there's three different types you've got
the attack plane the fighter plane and
the bomber the fighter plane only has
one seat in it so it's a bit like the
light tank is very maneuverable doesn't
do a lot of damage but it's very quick
so it can sort of get away get a few
kills and then go away loop back round
again if you use the attack plane you've
got a pilot in there he's got a front
gun you've also got a rear gunner as
well so if there's a plane chasing you
you can use that but you can also use it
to shoot targets on the ground and then
if you've got the bomber there's a pilot
who can I think you can use the ground
bombs who'd sort you can sort of like a
car fit of bombs and maybe go over an
objective
something like that I'd be something
could be if you guys can execute it that
have been really cool get some kills too
big if though yeah it's a big it's a big
if but I mean it could happen it could
happen there's a rear gunner a bit like
on the on the attack plane and on the
front gunner it's a big sort of machine
gun and it does damage against buildings
so you can destroy walls with it does
damage against tanks so it's a big heavy
round that can do some real damage so if
you're flying over an objective maybe
spot up some players on the ground using
the queue button and then just hammer
down some bullets and you'll probably
end up getting some kids should we just
go and join in the next game see what we
can do that's good cool stood and
Westies taught some very fundamental
Bert important mechanics I feel and
that's something we need to let have
become you know fluent rather than
something you have to think about it
some that you do automatically so I'm
going to give my best shot with some
planes and some tanks but in general I
just want to be more of a supportive
role and my favorite tank is gonna have
to be the light tank of one person tank
as well I'm quite a lone wolf when it
comes to vehicles I've always enjoyed
being in the tanks like taking apart
like being in the planes as well even
though I'm one of the worst pilots ever
become half expecting to crash into a
wall or something but we'll see how it
goes
if you use third person to line up your
shot and then switch the first person
when you're about to shoot
oh hello Phillip
you could just literally right past your
teammates and then you can just drop
health and ammo straightaway paper girl
from the side
you
play it first with EA access